- Is it true that your time off
you also took a class
on hostage negotiation?
We would vacation well together.
- [Lauren] We would for sure.
- I'd be like, sure.
- I belong to Masterclass.
You know the thing, you can
subscribe to Masterclass.
And it's all these experts on everything.
- Wait, what?
- And so I try to take something
that I wouldn't normally
use in daily life.
And one of them was hostage negotiating.
- But hopefully it doesn't come in handy.
- I hope not.
But I'm a handy person to have
if things go wrong on our summer vacation.
So I took hostage negotiating.
I took tortilla making.
I just try to take random stuff.
- I don't know this,
so I need to know this.
- It's really fun.
And the guy who teaches
hostage negotiating
is exactly who you'd cast to teach.
He's like, listen, this
is what you gotta do
when you're trying to talk
him down off the hill.
I don't know why we're on a hill.
- Off the hill?
Not a building.
(laughs)
- Don't jump off the hill.
- I've been taken hostage
in the fields of Montana.